so it's kind of nice right but of course
will you all not all of you but a lot of
you are kind of like when I wrote this
down what what made me think of writing
that down
okay now I actually dropped the clue a
few times I just tried to gloss over and
say you didn't notice me paying too much
attention to it well I said a great idea
would be to visualize what's going on I
said write something draw something I'm
gonna draw something okay I said if
algebra were off-limits
how could I represent this thing I love
perhaps Edna stood before you said how
could I represent squares numbers
squared in any way perhaps I could use a
square okay so I'm gonna take this line
I'm gonna take this line as my cue okay
so this is saying that there's a square
and it's one by one one by one and its
side like this a plus B plus C because a
plus people C is one okay now I control
every single combination ambien see
obviously that would be a million and
infinite number of diagrams all I need
to do is draw a diagram where the
concept the principle is there so for
instance if I make like a this length
over here and then maybe something like
that okay they go a bigger than these
you can see they're all positive
now of course this is not just a and B
and C this is a square so I need us I
need a here as well and something like
this billion
now remember I said to you there's a
nice and easy way to remember not that
you need to but that a plus B plus C
elsewhere
is this okay well if this is what I'm
squaring key then each of these
corresponds to a little slice of this
okay it's a slice for instance where is
the a squid slice it's there in the top
left corner you can see it function okay
I'm gonna turn all the way down actually
I figured there's I swear where's the B
Square slice it's just a bit further in
right if I go like that there's the B
squared slice and set in fact I'm gonna
label use a square and be spreading you
care with that and where's the C Spencer
I'm worried if you want to have enough
distance with okay now the question
becomes how did I know to make this
argument well I'm saying that this whole
thing should be less than 1 right and
this thing is equal to 1 so that means I
want to be able to fit all of these
somewhere inside and if it's less than
the whole area should have some cap
stuff going on I should have some gaps
all right let's let's fit them in a
squared B squared C squared we've
already picked them out so what's left
for me to place into the diagram there's
this 2 P squared which I haven't
accounted for and for C squared then I
also have an account look at this line
look at this line can you see visually
where that algebraic line fits in I
think it fits in
do you see it here's here's another B
Square I have to be able to fit a B
Square bit in there I have to be able to
cuz look I've got the width that's
correct
and I know that this is a which is
bigger than being right so look there's
um is leftover space and there's gonna
be leftover space here okay there I'd be
squids they've done where am I gonna fit
in my six squares ah okay so I've got
some space I've got one three four
they have to fit in there don't there
they have to because what the what's the
height here would see what's the width
it's B which must be bigger than C right
so here's another C square and another C
square I don't know if I can fit to see
squares in there I don't actually know
that because I don't know what B&C
actually are might be able to or I might
not which was some of the problems that
I spotted some people knew they could
draw something but it's like yeah you've
got to be careful where you're fit
things you have to your generalize I
know I can fix a square here because of
this line you see it see it sees less
than a so that's that's this rectangle
over here is AC you see that a C so the
C square and again I have a depth what's
a lot of
okay so what I would do what I would do
in fact not what I would do what I did
do right is that say okay okay I look I
look and I say is this some visual way
to understand what's going on here okay
and frequently there are squares squares
are nice to play with because they give
you areas and areas how is it you that's
another way of saying if you always if
you square a number you always get
something is you orbit up okay so if
you've got squares in there that makes
it sort of cannon fodder for doing a
diagram right and then I drew this thing
and then I said okay now how do I turn
this into algebra so I drew this first
this is not my proof in the same way
that diagram for a circular geometry
question is not your proof it's what
helps you work out what do I even write
that's that's how I knew to write this
because I was like how do I say that
that there's gap there and the answer is
because of that does that make sense so
whenever you encounter any kind of
inequality right if you've got something
which I could I draw it could I draw it
just you think of using that as a guide
to sort of do not get just algebra out
in random directions right it's a pretty
small number of lines right but you
wouldn't guess it until you okay